so in this movie you get to do pretty
much anything an actor can do on screen
like Aladdin's like he's a parkour
legend but also he's a Broadway singer
and he also he dances like Bruno Mars
like haha what was the most challenging
aspect you know just having to combine
things you know I think it's it's one
thing to stand in a room and sing or
dance but having to combine the singing
with the stunt work or combine the
dancing with the acting is is when it
gets challenging this is pretty much the
most visible role you could possibly do
because everybody in the world is gonna
see this movie so does that make you
nervous or are you excited about it or
how do you feel about it
you know I didn't have much time to
think about it all I knew is that this
was a film that I grew up watching and I
would have you know loved to play this
character so I didn't think too much
about the technicalities of it or who
would see it now that we're here I just
hope people go to the theater and enjoy
it and take something away from it
there's a lot of messages too to take
away so you know I hope people love it
so you mentioned you're a fan of the
movie as a kid what scene or sequence
were you most looking forward to doing
you know from the animation the friend
like me sequence was one of my favorites
because Robin Williams was an
inspiration of mine growing up to become
an actor but for this I was looking
forward to one jump you know it's his
first musical number and he gets to do
it while doing some pretty kick-ass
stunts so I was looking forward to that
yeah very cool how do you think Aladdin
and Abu met like that relationship well
I think he saved them
well when they were on the streets I
think he saw him as a young monkey
and he took him in he was an abandoned
Capuchin and he took him in and they
kind of cultivated the relationship that
way and I wanted to draw the parallel of
they were both grew up without having
parental figures so like Aladdin
Capuchin got you know left on the
streets at a young age do you think
Aladdin bought that outfit for a boo oh
yeah you know I think I think a lot and
probably gathered enough money once in
his life to get something made for him
because back then clothes you know I
think got custom-made and he probably
spent a little extra to get him a
similar outfit right it's a good gesture
for a man of limited means yeah yeah I
mean hey you got to take care of your
own right yeah for sure what was it like
doing your first camera test for this
movie it was intense
you know I was in London for a week
prepping for it I got to work with Jamal
Sims a choreographer and Claire
underwood my vocal coach and we that was
the first time that I got to work with
them so it was pretty surreal getting to
work with them for the test and then you
know having them for the actual
production what Disney Care did you
identify most with as a kid was it
Aladdin or yeah it was you know it's
he's the only character that I could
relate to growing up he's the only
character that looked like me had a
similar culture to mine you know so it
was it was definitely a lot do you think
if if they were to go on to do
adaptations of any of the sequels like
return of Jafar do you think you would
be willing to come back to do that oh I
mean absolutely I'd love to work with
guy again and the cast and the crew you
know I'd want to get back as many people
as we can who did this version and yeah
I totally be all-in